so in this video we're going to talk
about Euler's formula and one of the
things I want to start out with is why
why do we want to talk about this rather
odd looking formula what's what's the
big deal about this and there is there
is a big deal and the big deal is E
we love E and I'll underline that twice
now the reason is because when we take a
derivative of e D DT of e to the x
equals e to the X and D DT of e to the
ax so we're a is anything equals a e to
the ax and so the property is that when
you take a derivative of the function
the same function comes out or if you
take a derivative of the function a
scaled version of the same function
comes out and we love this because why
because when we do differential
equations e to the X is the solution
almost every time whenever we did a
circuit e to the X was the answer if you
recall from when we word solving
circuits simple circuits with
differential equations that we always
said something like well we're going to
guess that V of T is some constant times
e to the St that was a proposed solution
this turned out to work every time so
there's something else we love too and
that is sinusoidal cosines ok we love
these and that gets two lines now why do
we love these is because they happen in
nature if you whistle
the air pressure looks like a sine wave
if you ring a bell the bell moves in a
sine wave any kind of music if you look
at the notes and music the sound they
make the pressure waves look like sine
waves and circuits make sine waves
remember if we analyze this circuit in
great detail was the l-c circuit we
looked at the natural response of this
and
was a sine-wave okay
so electric circuits make sideways all
these things make sine waves they occur
in nature and we want to be able to
analyze things that happen when sine
waves are present so we have two things
we love and we want to relate these two
things and these are going to be related
through that Euler's formula that's how
we connect these two separate ideas and
let me let's go do that
so Oilers formula says that e to the J x
equals cosine X plus J times sine X
though Sal has a really nice video where
he actually proves that this is true and
he does it by taking the Maclaurin egg
series expansions of e and cosine and
sine and showing that this expression is
true by look by comparing those those
series expansions now I'm not going to
repeat that here we're just going to
state that as fact and now we're going
to look at this equation a little bit
more so this is this is the expression
that relates Exponential's that we love
to sines and cosines that we love and
part of the price of doing that is we
introduce complex numbers into our world
here's two complex numbers okay this is
where complex numbers come in to
electrical engineering so I have to
mention the other form of this formula
which is e to the I put a minus sign in
here e to the minus J X and that equals
cosine X minus J sine X so these two
these two expressions together are
Euler's formula or Euler's formulas and
we're going to exploit this by taking
we'll be able to take the cosines and
sines that we find in nature we're going
to be able to fashion them into
Exponential's and these Exponential's
then go into our differential equations
and give us solutions and we're going to
come back and pull out the cosines and
sines that's the rhythm of how we're
going to use this equation to help us
solve solve circuits one small point I
want to share notice that in both these
equations the cosine comes first and the
sine is over here on the imaginary side
so the cosine is on the real side this
is the reason that we have a preference
in the future we're going to have a
preference for talking about our
real-world signals in terms of the
cosine function it's because in this
Euler's formula the cosine comes first
in both cases so what I want to do now
is take a take a second and I want to
see if we had our our signal expressed
in these Exponential's how do we recover
the cosine and the sine term how do we
how do we flip these equations around so
we can solve for the cosine and the sine
it's a simple bit of algebra here it's
good to see all right so if I want to
isolate the cosine term if I want to
isolate the cosine term let me let me
get rid of these guys here
so now to isolate the cosine term what
I'm going to do is add these two
equations together and that plus and
minus are going to cancel out this
second term here that's what I'm going
for
so if I add I'll get e to the J X plus e
to the minus J x equals cosine doubles
two cosine X and the two sine terms
cancel out right so then I can write
I'll write it over here I can write
cosine of X equals e to the plus J X
plus e to the minus J x over 2 all right
so that's the expression that's the
expression for cosine in terms of
complex Exponential's ok let's go back
and see if we can get sine so what I'm
going to do with sign is I'm going to
subtract
and that gives me what that'll do is
it'll get the cosine terms to fall away
and then I get e to the J X subtracting
right minus e to the minus J x equals
cosine terms I'm going they subtract out
and I get two times J times sine X all
right and that means I can write sine x
equals e to the plus J X minus e to the
minus J x over two J and it's real easy
don't that J term is down there that's
easy to forget sometimes so they put a
square around these guys because that's
important so there's the two expressions
that's the two expressions for if you
have complex Exponential's and you want
to extract the cosine this is how you do
it if you want to extract the sine this
is how you do it
okay and you can either you know you can
put these in your head or probably
easier for me if you just remember
Oilers formula this is a pretty
straightforward quick derivation so the
other thing we put a square around is
this guy here so we have Euler's formula
and basically the cosine and sine
extracted from Euler's formula